hey guys O'Brien right I'm Michael Arno
yeah that's is your name good yeah
you're always do you like my ejaculation
delight anyway we're gonna check out the
trailer for All Hallows Eve I figure
Halloween is like you know soon two
months or something but it's what are
you gonna be I mean I I think I'm gonna
be a dick head
like a [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah so yourself
yeah yeah but with an extension okay
like again an erect cellphone myself
just my dick Hey okay so let's watch the
trailer yeah yeah tell me about it it's
already been quite an eventful evening
some creeps up to videotape me to
Timmy's candy bag while we were
trick-or-treating you should see what's
on it
Oh
oh I'm turning it off - violet for the
two of you do you think that clown no
it's just maple humans which is monsters
that doesn't exist
who's following you
but damn it's just a series of scary
images they show us and I don't scare
easily because I I've seen somebody
movies but that looked scary
that looks pretty scary yeah that looks
creepy mm-hmm and what was that alien
thing with the to be armed
I have no idea I've been okay first off
I know you've heard me say this about
other trailers who the acting does not
look that good to me sorry I say well
you've been wrong I have been wrong
before I am but the acting in this one
look now the mom or the babysitter
whoever she's supposed to know you were
such a critic of performance who did you
have a problem with in this trailer the
woman on the phone is you mom or
babysitter or something so you just
start critiquing her looks such a bland
performance uber of the images were seen
I can't judge the whole performance I'm
saying it looks like she's not going to
give it could perform it I believed her
as a woman talking on the phone you
believe her as a woman it's not hard to
believe her as a woman but who is she
she looks familiar
I have no idea let's IMDB Katie McGuire
Katie McGuire name sounds very familiar
uh-huh no I haven't seen her in anything
she was in Sex in the City as a waitress
once but it was uncredited okay I might
have caught her in that yeah everyone
these days feels like clowns are scared
you know like clowns are easy to be you
know they're easier to be scary than
they are to be childlike know like they
freak people out yeah rightfully so the
whole theme of like Oh scary clowns I'm
kind of getting past but this looks like
it's going all out with violence and
that kind of intrigues me well in this
clown let's look at the let's get an
image of the clown because he looked is
makeup designers like Multan points
who
no he's he's scary-looking
yeah he's scary-looking but still I'm I
mean is there really a plot to this
killing peeps are nodding videotapes and
the moms so stupid like oh this stranger
drops the videotaping here let's all
watch the videotape yeah that was young
that is so dumb but I don't care I mean
it looks scary I'll check it out you
know you know what you have changed my
opinion yeah I'm not I'm not looking for
a lot of plot in this movie I'm looking
for scary clowns some jump scares yes
okay unsubtle know what you're right I
was being a little too hard the fact is
that what you want from it you're
probably gonna get yeah exactly
okay you know what Michael this is not
an Oscar bait film if you were a
Christian talking to me about the Lord
and Savior I would have been converted
yeah because you have done that with the
trailer all I need use my words more
often it wasn't even just that was your
words it's who you are that speaks so
much you say you have to say so little
to convince it convince you yeah it was
real yeah they just kind of just slipped
out it was just what I felt about this
trailer and apparently it resonated with
you so so thank you thank you thank you
thank you so you see this will go for
this yeah as long as this film is like
really entertaining and fast-paced I
think I could be on board for it because
at the end of the day I don't feel like
I'm gonna give a [ __ ] about anyone in
this movie because you know like the
best horror films are the ones are you
really what about you don't care about
Timmy just cuz he's a kid I don't want
to see him die but at the same time I
don't really care about you have a
dooming his name - Timmy I know
everyone's [ __ ] name is anymore
Crohn's is their new Timmy you gotta
love what some of this does feel a
little homage you know yeah yeah ring to
it ring you know ring
it's me ringing a Kappa no ring Naomi
Watts movie a little video that's oh you
mean yo so ring yeah the ring
don't just say ring next time that's
very it's called a the ring you said
it's got a little bit of ring - oh yeah
but the original was called brain goo
so oh yeah isn't renew I don't know yeah
well maybe well I don't you American
flames to speak Japanese
yeah those Eve looks like a fun spooky
time all I hope is that it's a really
entertaining film that's that's all I
care about is just fast paced fun
because I'm not gonna give a [ __ ] about
these characters so I want at least it
to just make up for lack of characters
with just a fun bad [ __ ] scary yeah [ __ ]
yeah exact do you think it will be at
like an insidious level cuz into town is
no no and insidious had like really good
acting and yeah tension-filled this is
like it was great it looks like best
scary creepy images but the creepy
factor looks like maybe on an insidious
level creepy was like is so unsettling
and insidious and it gets under your
skin this is like more jump this is more
like this creepy to look at anyway guys
yeah thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects Michael is one of the
stars and producers of the film I got to
open at Comic Con called circle yeah he
is gonna be in that film he is already
in the film what am I talking about and
let's do that again he is one of the
stars you could catch that film in
October he's also putting a short film
together well I put it together it's red
Diaries what's your short film called
Dennis doesn't literary I don't know I
got red guy I don't even I thought you
were going somewhere and but that's
gonna be it so I was going somewhere and
I went nowhere it's a story of my life
it's like you keep running you know what
I mind you on the channel so I can make
as many circle jokes as possible but not
one circle joke ya know which we thought
was good we got a shout out coming up
yeah follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine periscope
jarring downing what a horrible name
downing downing that's like putting
people down why would you do that jar
I'm downing dear real rejects can I get
shout out watch your channel almost two
years
jarring down in let's see what you look
like buddy what roast okay you ready for
this Michael yeah we're gonna see who's
gonna enter the circle jerk uh uh a lot
of people that's gonna be successful you
look younger though does he look too
young to be a part of it well I'm just
gonna assume Ya Ya though some of these
I don't know I don't know it's hard to
tell there's a shirtless pic there and I
feel like you should be over 18 if
you're gonna put one of those yeah if
you're gonna put one even though it's
early I mean you got a great body I mean
I wouldn't mind you being part of the
circle I'm not gonna make a comment
until i have confirmation over 18 well
you know the audience doesn't know who
exactly we're looking at well you said
his name says his name but there's many
Jarrah
Downey's I don't know about that it's a
pretty unique name he seems like a cool
dude though so I had met many a jarn
Downing's no one's gonna know who this
one is but you've been in a lot of
circle jerks oh yeah sure many there's
always like one or two John's oh it's
like when you go to an Italian family
and you're like hey Paul hey Murray yeah
you know it's like that with Circle
Jerks well yeah I mean you would your
hands you wouldn't know
okay yeah shows done we're done we're
done we're done over its up got awkward